you know I've been researching
entrepreneurship I've been researching
immigrant entrepreneurship in particular
and what I learned was that Silicon
Valley was amazingly diverse that 52% of
her startups were founded by people like
me people born abroad and I thought it
was a perfect meritocracy and we moved
to Silicon Valley about four four and a
half years ago and I do a lot of writing
I wrote a blog for TechCrunch my wife
and I happen to go to TechCrunch event
called the crunchies and it was a great
event you know the Oscars of the tech
industry and in the middle of it my wife
said vague do you notice something
strange
I said yeah we sitting next to Mark
Zuckerberg isn't that cool she says no
look around what don't you see here I
mean she was getting frustrated with me
and I didn't notice anything strange
then she says where the women and it was
like a light went off in my head saying
you know what is going on here it's like
you know it's a surreal experience you
know Twilight Zone sort of that you
notice something is completely missing
so I started noticing what was happening
on stage about a hundred 450 people on
stage not a single woman other than a
couple of staff I started looking around
at the composition of Silicon Valley
companies hardly any women I started
looking at the boards of companies I
looking on the websites
no women and it was a surreal experience
I mean what is going on here why aren't
there women in Silicon Valley how can
you have the most innovative land on
this planet not have women how can you
be leaving out the most productive part
of our population so that's really what
triggered this whole this whole reaction
often and why become so vocal about the
lack of women in innovation I happen to
write a blog saying titled Silicon
Valley you and your venture capitalist
have a gender problem you know I
basically detailed my observations about
there not being women and then I
detailed some of the academic research I
had done I was stunned at the negative
reaction to it I was stunned at the
volley of criticism on social media
the angry comments posted online I was
stunned at the emails I was getting even
for my friends because I realized I know
who's who Silicon Valley
and some of these are the moguls over
there they advised me to stay off this
topic they advised me that if you look
like you're new to Silicon Valley if you
want to make it here this is not the way
if you're trying to get laid we can help
you with those are the type of comments
I was getting back and I was actually
shocked I mean I was insensitive to the
issue of gender I mean I've never been
at one extreme or the other but this
sort of opened my eyes to the harsh
reality and what my wife still in there
said was the way you know look at what
you're going through
imagine what women go through every day
of their lives and that is really what
put me on this crusade to try to fix
this gender gap and to be vocal about it
it starts off with these sexist
attitudes that that men have it starts
out with their sense of superiority and
then it it's also the upbringing that
women have that from childhood they
given Barbie dolls the guys are given
you know masculine toys and then women
are discouraged from studying computing
in science and engineering because those
are guys things and some of them do have
enlightened parents who encourage them
to achieve their potential and and to
change the world and they go to school
and they're treated different because
they happen to be interested in science
and and engineering and mathematics
they're called
you know the women equivalent of geeks
and nerds or worse they look down at and
then they get into college and they're
one of very few women in it they
struggle they defy the odds they go into
the workplace and guess what it's all
male and and they're one of the few
women in their workplace and they treat
it differently even though they may be
as competent they may have better skills
than the men do they don't get the same
promotions they get looked down at and
it's even worse than that I tell you the
type of stories I've heard really
disturbed me women being raped go by me
and just just just you know I don't want
one repeated it's just sort of horrible
the stories I've heard from women
heart-wrenching stories of how women
have been treated by men this is just
outrageous it's not acceptable I mean
this is a civilized society we live in
how dare we treat the better half of our
population like this first of all if you
look at the graduation rates they're 140
women for every 100 men
now coming out of higher education women
are equally proficient in mathematics
sciences every field of education do you
look at women are equal to a better than
men then when it comes to a technology
sector in particular if you look at the
way the venture capital system works
it's based on a failure rate of 80 or 90
percent that's because they invest in
all these brain-dead companies and the
founders spend money like there's no
tomorrow and and they lose all this
money and venture capital as a as a
asset class doesn't decline because of
that so in other words we're wasting
tens of billions of dollars on funding
brain-dead companies what's the
difference with women women tend to be
more sensible they tend also tend to
have more empathy you know I'm not
trying to say that women are better or
worse than men over here but women have
a maternal instinct they have more of a
desire to care for others than do men so
when it comes to things like design it's
all about empathy if you can feel what
your users need you can design better so
therefore women should make better
designers women also more sensible it's
again getting to the maternal instinct
that they know how to manage budgets
better they're more responsible because
of the roles that they've had so if they
become CEOs they they produce better
financial results and these are backed
up by research when they join boards
when you have enough critic when you
have critical mass of women the guide
the company is better the companies
produce better performance so you have
more innovation you have better
financial management you have greater
success rates by having more women why
leave them out there half of our
population all of the research that's
been done says that company is founded
by women have higher success rates they
spend less money they produce better
results it's really that simple
that financial management is better and
they do tend to do more sensible things
than these brain-dead companies built by
my brat friends in Silicon Valley
you